marvel fans are getting excited to see
if chris hemsworth and mark ruffalo will
reunite in avengers secret wars we'll
find out in 2025 when it's released but
i got mark talking about keeping up
their blockbuster bond
you like excited to get back on set at
some point together hey
hey we know each other he's a friend
from work yes i was disappointed that i
wasn't in love and thunder but uh
but i still love him
and we're gonna make more thunder
how do you think this will compare to
end game well it's going to be hard to
top end game but
i know marvel it's going to be pretty
amazing we'll go out with a big bang
but first mark's co-starring with
tatiana maslany and she-hulk attorney at
law she's newly blonde and newly wed to
actor brendan hines in a secret ceremony
what can you tell me what's new about
married library
i don't know it's really just fun it's
like we're having a blast it's fun to i
don't know
yes yes yes
no tatiana is the hulk's cousin in the
nine episode series dropping thursday on
disney plus and yeah she's an attorney
so think of it as a legal comedy with
superheroes cause we didn't ask for this
but you still gotta deal with it you're
the first solo hulk project i mean
that's gotta be such an honor right it's
great
i beat the boys
jamila jamil co-stars as the villain the
stunt training the wire work what'd you
get to get into for this oh i did it all
i did it all i was hurting in places
that i really didn't know exist like i
didn't um you'll probably have to bleep
this out but i pulled a muscle in my
oh wow didn't know that was possible
[Music]